Good morning, everyone. Hello. Hi. Hi. We are excited. Very excited. We are popping into your feeds today to give you a special top of the year Office Ladies announcement.
大家早上好。你好。嗨。嗨。我们很兴奋。非常兴奋。我们今天出现在你们的订阅源中，是为了发布一个特别的年度Office Ladies公告。
As of today, Office Ladies has expanded to be a network. A network. We're a network lady. And we want to tell you about the first podcast joining the Office Ladies Network. It is a podcast called The Lazy Genius with Kendra Adachi. We are so thrilled to have Kendra join the Office Ladies Network. We wanted to share with you an excerpt from her podcast. This week's episode is called Starting Fresh When You Can't Start Over.
从今天起，Office Ladies已经扩展为一个网络。一个网络。我们现在是一个网络女士了。我们想告诉你们加入Office Ladies网络的第一档播客。它是一档名为《The Lazy Genius with Kendra Adachi》的播客。我们非常激动Kendra能加入Office Ladies网络。我们想与你们分享她播客中的一个片段。本周的剧集名为《当你无法从头开始时，如何焕然一新》。
We hope that you'll give it a listen and love it as much as we do. I think we need a fresh take on January energy. We need some new words when we feel this compulsion to start over. I shared some of these words last January, actually, and I need the reminder just as much as anyone. So we're going to look at those words again. The first word that will help us start fresh instead of starting over is continue. Continue.
我们希望你们能去听一听，并像我们一样喜欢它。我认为我们需要对一月份的能量有一个全新的认识。当我们感到这种从头开始的冲动时，我们需要一些新的词汇。事实上，去年一月我分享过其中一些词，我像任何人一样需要提醒。所以我们要再次审视这些词。第一个能帮助我们焕然一新而不是从头开始的词是“继续”。继续。
Instead of beginning, continue. Everything you do builds on what has come before. You're living a beautiful, sometimes messy life, and it's a continuation. January does not have to be a restart. It is not necessarily a new beginning. Now, energetically, there are some really helpful things about those feelings of January, of the literal turning of the calendar, but that does not require you to begin everything anew. In fact, you can't, that takes so much work. Instead, if you feel the pressure to begin something that
与其开始，不如继续。你所做的一切都建立在过去的基础上。你正在过着一种美好、有时混乱的生活，这是一种延续。一月不必是重启。它不一定是一个新的开始。现在，从能量上讲，关于一月份的那些感觉，关于日历的字面翻转，确实有一些非常有帮助的事情，但这并不要求你一切从头开始。事实上，你做不到，那需要太多的工作。相反，如果你感到压力去开始某件事，而这件事
does not truly align with what matters to you, simply continue, continue doing what you're doing, knowing that you're not failing anything by not starting over, by not beginning again, just because it's January. Continue. You're really smart. You're probably already doing a lot of great things
并不真正符合你所看重的东西，那就简单地继续，继续做你正在做的事情，要知道仅仅因为是一月，不从头开始，不重新开始，并不意味着你在任何事情上失败了。继续。你真的很聪明。你可能已经在做很多伟大的事情了
that don't need a reset. They don't even need tinkering with. Just continue. And the places that you know what matters and you know what works most of the time continue. The second word is tend. Don't fix tend.
它们不需要重置。它们甚至不需要修补。只需继续。在那些你知道什么重要、你知道什么在大多数时候有效的地方，继续。第二个词是“照料”。不要修复，要照料。
Now don't get me wrong. There are things that need fixing. They need to be, you know, taken apart and put back together. But usually that stuff like toilets or an Ikea closet that was not installed correctly, we fix things. We can't exactly fix life, but we sure do try, don't we? We come at it like a certain part of our life is a problem to solve and to fix
现在别误会我的意思。有些事情确实需要修复。它们需要，你知道的，拆开再重新组装。但通常那些东西，比如马桶或安装不正确的宜家衣柜，我们修复它们。我们不能确切地修复生活，但我们确实在尝试，不是吗？我们对待它就像我们生活中的某一部分是一个需要解决和修复的问题
when really most of our lives need nurturing and tending. They need compassion alongside correcting. And when we compassionately correct one small thing at a time, that is tending. That's looking at what's there with kind eyes, not going too fast, and taking it one step at a time. That is so much more sustainable than continuously taking apart and putting back together all the systems and processes and goals of your life. So think about where you feel the need to fix. And if instead, you need to tend. The third word is small. I love small things. I love small choices, small differences, small steps, small problems. That's why one of the 13 lazy genius principles is to start small.
而实际上我们的大多数生活需要滋养和照料。它们需要同情心以及纠正。当我们带着同情心一次纠正一件小事时，那就是照料。那是用友善的眼光看待现状，不要走得太快，一步一个脚印。这比不断地拆开和重新组装你生活中的所有系统、流程和目标要可持续得多。所以想想你在哪里感到需要修复。如果相反，你需要照料。第三个词是“小”。我喜欢小事物。我喜欢小的选择、小的差异、小的步骤、小的问题。这就是为什么13个Lazy Genius原则之一是从小处着手。
The smaller something is, the easier it is to solve, to tend to, to manage, to live with, to incorporate into your life on a regular basis. But January energy is big energy, right? It's big swings, big systems, big changes. And that's why we can't stick with anything. We're starting with big problems, and big problems require big solutions. I don't know about you,
某件事越小，就越容易解决、照料、管理、共处，并定期融入你的生活。但一月份的能量是巨大的能量，对吧？是大动作、大系统、大变革。这就是为什么我们无法坚持任何事情。我们从大问题开始，而大问题需要大的解决方案。我不知道你们怎么样，
but I don't have room for big solutions right now. Life is beautifully unwieldy, and inviting big systems, or big goals, or big solutions into that is almost impossible. And when those big things don't work and they won't, I want to start over. I want to call them all again and get to try again so that what came before wasn't a failure.
但我现在没有空间容纳大的解决方案。生活是美丽而难以驾驭的，引入大的系统、大的目标或大的解决方案几乎是不可能的。当那些大的东西不起作用时——它们确实不会起作用——我就想从头开始。我想再次全部推倒重来，这样过去的一切就不会被视为失败。
Instead, let's start small. Like really, really embarrassingly small. I told a story in my first book, The Lazy Genius Way, about how I started small with yoga. I have terrible joints, as well as like a lot of frantic mental energy. I call myself a caffeinated squirrel. And consequently, being a caffeinated squirrel with hips and knees that are basically made of glass, yoga is really good for me. It's good for my joints and for my brain.
相反，让我们从小处着手。就像非常、非常令人尴尬的小。我在我的第一本书《The Lazy Genius Way》中讲过一个故事，关于我是如何从小处着手练习瑜伽的。我的关节很糟糕，而且有很多狂躁的心理能量。我称自己为咖啡因松鼠。因此，作为一个有着基本上由玻璃制成的臀部和膝盖的咖啡因松鼠，瑜伽对我真的很好。它对我的关节和大脑都有好处。
Well, years and years ago, I knew this and tried to incorporate more yoga into my life, but I could not make it work. I couldn't get it to stick. And I got so frustrated by that because it mattered to me. Like it, yoga mattered to me for reasons that felt right and good and aligned with tending to my body, but I just couldn't seem to get into a rhythm at all. And you know what I did? I just kept restarting. I kept restarting the commitment counter to zero over and over again. And that
嗯，多年前，我知道这一点并试图将更多的瑜伽融入我的生活，但我无法让它奏效。我无法坚持下去。我对此感到非常沮丧，因为它对我来说很重要。就像它，瑜伽对我来说很重要，原因感觉正确、良好，并且与照料我的身体相一致，但我似乎根本无法进入节奏。你知道我做了什么吗？我只是不断地重启。我一次又一次地将承诺计数器重置为零。而那
was also defeating. So I tried, I tried a new approach. I made doing yoga embarrassingly small. I said that I would do one down dog a day. One down dog a day. If you're unfamiliar with yoga, that's basically like bending over once a day and sticking your butt in the air. Some might argue that's not even yoga, but it was so small that I did it.
也令人沮丧。所以我尝试了，我尝试了一种新方法。我让做瑜伽变得令人尴尬地小。我说我每天做一个下犬式。每天一个下犬式。如果你不熟悉瑜伽，那基本上就像每天弯腰一次，把屁股翘在空中。有些人可能会说那甚至算不上瑜伽，但它太小了，以至于我做到了。
I did this thing that mattered to me, but it was so small that I did it. I did this thing that mattered to me. And because it was so small and doable, over time I built on it. And hear me, when I say over time, I don't mean like days later. I'm pretty sure I did one down dog a day for weeks and weeks without much difference. Some of those days I would do like a full sun salutation,
我做了这件对我重要的事情，但它太小了，以至于我做到了。我做了这件对我重要的事情。因为它是如此之小且可行，随着时间的推移，我在此基础上进行了积累。听我说，当我说随着时间的推移，我并不是指几天后。我很确定我连续几周又几周地每天做一个下犬式，没有太大的区别。有些日子我会做一个完整的拜日式，
which still only takes like 60 seconds. But I didn't change what the daily habit was of one down dog a day for literal months. But guess what? I did yoga every day. It was so small that it became part of my life and my routine in a way that worked, in a way that supported what mattered. So your third word is small, even embarrassingly small. Nothing is too small. Don't start over, start fresh by starting small. I just love the way Kendra breaks it down. I just love it.
这仍然只需要大约60秒。但我几个月来都没有改变每天做一个下犬式的习惯。但你猜怎么着？我每天都做瑜伽。它太小了，以至于它以一种有效的方式、以一种支持重要事物的方式成为了我生活和日常的一部分。所以你的第三个词是“小”，甚至是令人尴尬地小。没有什么太小了。不要从头开始，通过从小处着手来焕然一新。我真的很喜欢Kendra的拆解方式。我真的很喜欢。
I know, she's the best. If you want to hear the full episode, which I hope you do, head over to the Lazy Genius podcast wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can find Kendra at thelazygeniuscollective.com slash Office Ladies, and we'll share a link in our Instagram stories as well. And please join us next Monday for a special episode, Office Ladies Monday Motivation with Kendra. We had the best conversation with her and we can't wait to share it with you. Listen, if anyone's going to motivate you on a Monday, it's Kendra.
我知道，她是最好的。如果你想听完整的一集，我希望你听，前往Lazy Genius播客，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你可以在thelazygeniuscollective.com/OfficeLadies找到Kendra，我们也会在我们的Instagram故事中分享链接。请下周一加入我们，收听特别节目，Office Ladies周一动力与Kendra。我们与她进行了最好的对话，我们迫不及待地想与你们分享。听着，如果有人要在周一激励你，那就是Kendra。
That's right. Welcome to the Office Ladies Network, Kendra. We're so excited to have you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没错。欢迎加入Office Ladies网络，Kendra。我们非常高兴有你的加入。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。